what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to geek culture explain and
are y'all digging the Captain America
shirt what do you think about the
Captain America shirt it's pretty
awesome isn't it we're going to be
talking about whether or not the MCU
phase four is really that bad so buckle
up chaps this is gonna be an opinion
piece so one of the things that people
are saying about phase four in the MCU
is that it feels scatterbrained that is
sort of all over the place and doesn't
really seem to have an identity on the
film side I would say that's not the
case on the TV side I would say that
seems to be the case now the film side
we'll talk about here in a second but
with the TV side it seems to lack what
the film side had and here's what I mean
by that when it came to the movies the
first 10 years those had a Direction
they had a goal and we knew what that
goal was basically after the first
Avengers film we didn't really know up
to that point right we basically just
got what we're a series of origin movies
but because they were so new and because
they were so fresh we didn't really care
we were just kind of like these movies
are phenomenal and we called it a day
when Avengers hit and we got the
post-credits scene with Thanos basically
being revealed to us that even if you
didn't know who that was having gone to
see the movie because of just all the
news coverage you basically learned
pretty quickly that Thanos and The
Infinity Gauntlet were coming hand in
hand which meant that somewhere along
the LA fine we were going to get the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline that of
course turned out to be true and
following the first Avengers film going
up to what was basically Infinity war in
Avengers in-game even if not every movie
a good example being Captain America and
the Winter Soldier but even if not every
movie tied directly into the journey
towards the infinity Saga meaning it
didn't feature the Infinity Stones in
some capacity it was all just part of
that Journey so we just kind of call it
a day when it comes to the DV side we
don't really have that we don't know
what the end goal is when it comes to
the TV shows they're just projects that
Marvel's sending out there now I say
that because Marvel hasn't really given
us a definitive goal Marvel hasn't said
here's the purpose of the TV shows
here's the purpose of the films done and
done because I think even to a degree
Marvel is figuring that out now I
personally look at the TV shows from the
perspective that they're more just
marvel being experimental Marvel's just
trying things that they find to be
intriguing just to sort of give
something a little more significance
here I'm not against it right I mean
She-Hulk doesn't have anything to do
with anything it doesn't tie into
anything at all and in fact this is
probably the first Marvel Cinematic
Universe project they've released where
there's no real fight scenes to be had
in this show in any capacity it's just
following the Journey of Jennifer
Walters as she deals with the kind of
things that women have to deal with on a
regular basis I'm not the target
audience for She-Hulk I'm not the
audience that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is going after and I think
there might be a bit of an instance
where people who are out there watching
the MCU are just like of course I'm a
target audience I've been watching these
movies the whole time but the reality
here is that I think this is one of
those instances when Marvel's just like
let's make something that's not designed
for the guy who loves to watch Thor and
Hulk face off against some villain out
there somewhere right or something along
those lines I think that what they're
doing is they're saying what if we told
a story that basically just resonated
with women more than anything else what
if we did that and then we get She-Hulk
right what if we tie into the horror
genre of things what are we trying to
like scary stuff right well there's
werewolf by night that kind of thing I
think is what they're doing with the TV
shows but at the same time that sort of
brand of Comedy that is very significant
in phase four I can see where it is a
bit jarring to people because when you
go into things like Thor love and
thunder and you basically have a movie
that features one of the most dangerous
villains ever in the history of Marvel
Comics who actually at one point became
a whole universe Believe It or Not Gore
became a universe unto himself it was
kind of nuts but when you take a villain
that's significant and then you put him
in a film where it basically just feels
more like a comedy than anything else
that can be jarring especially coming
off the heels of infinity war end
Avengers endgame where things were so
dark there wasn't really any easing into
this right it was literally us going
down this path and then we get to
Infinity war in Avengers end game then
it was a hard right and that was
basically it and it takes people off
guard it sort of just shocks them a
little bit and the reality here is that
when it comes to human beings right
wrong or otherwise we can't just change
all of a sudden right we have to sort of
be eased in to change it's the nature of
human beings the Marvel Cinematic
Universe kind of seems to be ignoring
that and saying well if you don't like
it that's your problem right we got
Disney money son holla wait we ain't
worried about that I don't know if
that's really the case or not but the
fact remains here that I think that that
sort of jarring sudden turn is what
really throws people off to it and
instead of people actually giving it a
chance what you have is a subsect of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Community who
is saying that's different from what I'm
used to I don't like it right and in
response to that they kind of feed into
whatever logic or Reason makes sense to
them for some of the people out there
they just don't like She-Hulk because
she's a woman in position of authority
let's just be honest with ourselves
right like there are some people out
there who are like that they can apply
smoke and mirrors and do a song in a
dance but at the end of the day we all
really know what's going on with them I
think another thing that's going on here
and I think it's something that was easy
to ignore before when it came to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies they
followed a very formulaic approach to
things right it was a very easy formula
to follow and there's no doubting that
it was successful right they had
multiple billion dollar fills but I
think that now we're sort of starting
from scratch to a degree again not on
the film side but on the TV show side
people are starting to see that formula
people are starting to see how copy
pasta the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
from one project to the next do I think
it's going to stay that way no I think
they stuck with that recipe for the
first 10 years because they knew it
would work and they knew that it would
pay off when it came to Infinity war and
Avengers end game I think that the sort
of difference in terms of characters
that they're introducing here and the
way they're introducing these characters
especially on the TV side it's designed
to counteract the formulaic method for
creating products but when you look at
the design the overall look of She-Hulk
in relation like how the character is
designed I'm not gonna lie basically
take all of the exposition aspects of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe films that
made you board put it in a TV show and
that's She-Hulk right there's like no
fighting here nothing happens over the
course of this show but again I'm not
the target audience so having talked to
Mariah for example it resonates with her
more than it does with me because that's
the the kind of stuff women have to put
up with on a regular basis I will say
probably the most unrealistic thing
about She-Hulk up to this point is the
fact that she would like create a dating
profile even as just a chick and not
have like a thousand hits in the first
day right that's the most unrealistic
and ridiculous thing I think what was
going on there is that if what we did is
we took away the 1 000 responses on a
dating app and we only focus on her
getting the responses from people that
she actually liked that was the that was
the manifestation in that show right
that's basically what that was right it
was it was kind of like yeah here are
the hits that I actually liked which
were like the five and we're gonna say I
only got five right because I guess
maybe that's how women view dating apps
I have no idea but I think that one of
the biggest issues the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has right now when it comes to
phase four and I think this feeds into
the issue of it potentially feeling
scatterbrained is that there's no
Flagship there's no one leading the
charge when it came to the first 10
years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you had Captain America and you had Iron
Man and each of them were sort of a
flagship in different ways and they
really complimented each other so Tony
Stark was the face of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he was Spider-Man's
popular it was great seeing Tom Holland
but by the time Spider-Man was rolled in
during Civil War Robert Downey Jr had
been Iron Man for so long he's the guy
that we liked right the Marvel Cinematic
Universe started with him he's the one
we latched on to and ultimately he
became the face of the mcu's franchise
for that 10-year period but where Iron
Man was the face of the MCU we all knew
at the end of the day as soon as Captain
America was announced and as soon as
they introduced him into the MCU he
would be the leader of the Avengers once
that team was formed and when it was
formed he was the leader and then
following everything that happened when
it came to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and the Avengers roster itself he was
the leader of the team so they really
complimented each other in that way the
model Cinematic Universe doesn't have
that right now right it just kind of
feels scattered leaderless and divided
and we don't know who's running the show
there's no Iron Man there's no Captain
America we know that or Spider-Man but
literally the entirety of Spider-Man no
way home was making the world forget
that Peter Parker ever existed so no one
knows who it is that's under the mask as
far as the films go and you feel that in
the movies Doctor Strange is doing his
own magical thing now I don't think it
intended to be this way I'm pretty sure
it's been well established that Chadwick
Boseman was going to be the face of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe going forward
he was essentially going to take the
Reigns following Robert Downey Jr's
departure from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and we all would have loved
that it was just a natural progression
because of how much we loved Chadwick
Boseman and the first black panther film
the problem with this is that
unfortunately Chadwick Boseman passed
away and what I think this did is it
threw a wrench in the works of the MCU
that they had projects lined up they had
things that they were focusing on but I
think what they're doing right now is
they're shuffling around and they're
trying to figure out who's going to be
the one to lead the charge here who's
going to be the one to run the show here
because as it stands right now there
aren't really any viable candidates in
that way Steven strange is so far
removed with the magical stuff that is
hard to see him taking over The Avengers
because the reality is he's never really
felt like he was a part of the larger
Marvel Cinematic Universe landscape he's
just kind of out there doing his thing
and pops up from time to time and then
you had Carol Danvers I don't know how
well people would receive her character
because as I understand it she was not
well received top to bottom that it was
guys and gals right people just in
general didn't seem to like Harold
Danvers again it could be Spider-Man but
that problem is a problem of its own and
so that's one of the things to contend
with here that's one of the issues to
look at if I'm a betting man and if I'm
being honest with you guys I think
that's why they're having so much
discussion about Deadpool 3 because I
think that with the popularity of
Deadpool being what it is Deadpool's
gonna get rolled in and Deadpool's gonna
be the face of the company but that
presents a problem in and of itself and
I think that presents a huge
misunderstanding of Deadpool when it
came to his popularity the reality of
why Deadpool was so popular when it came
to both the movie lineup as well as even
the comics themselves actually mirror
each other so like when Deadpool was
first introduced to Marvel Comics back
in the 90s he was every high octane
fast-paced superhero ever hyper violent
and all that kind of stuff it wasn't
until Joe Kelly started writing him in
like 1997 and 1998 then he started
breaking the fourth wall he only did it
twice during Joe Kelly's run but he
basically became a comedic character
whenever you guys think about Deadpool
being zany and crazy and breaking the
fourth wall that was Gail Simone and
Christopher priest back in the the late
90s and the early 2000s they're the ones
that made that happen but when you look
at Deadpool in terms of the movie
landscape he was totally different he
broke the fourth wall he made fun of the
status quo of like how comic book movies
were he made fun of the characters that
we just didn't really find to be
interesting that's what made him really
really intriguing and that's what made
him funny and so if you take that
element and then you suddenly give it to
everybody it stops being unique and
everything that made Deadpool
interesting totally Falls flat now again
this is just me speculating this is just
me throwing it out there I could be
entirely wrong I have no clue what the
plans are when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as much as I would
love to be one of the guys on the inside
helping them build the X-Men Kevin feige
if you see this video for the love of
God
just let me help you guys build the
X-Men I'll do it for free man I will do
it for free just have a credit at the
end of the movie that just says Rob
Comics explained Jefferson that's all I
want at the end of the X-Men film it's
the only thing that I want right just
that right I will I will sign a contract
saying that I'll do it for free man I
don't care I just want to be able to say
that I contributed to building the X-Men
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
don't care about the financial side but
nonetheless as much as I wish I was a
guy on the inside
I'm not and so I'm not purviewed to the
kind of information that they have and
what it is that they're working on but
what I want to know is this I want to
know your all's thoughts on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe phase four do you
love it do you hate it how do you feel
about She-Hulk how do you feel about all
that stuff right it's one of those
things where you're like I'm just not
really feeling I just want to get back
to the days when we had Infinity war and
Avengers end game are you one of those
people where nostalgia's just kind of
taking hold and you're having a
difficult time moving past are you one
of those folks where you're just kind of
like I'm just not feeling it let me know
what you all think down in the comments
section but thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace